they came to be very concerned and they
wanted to find a way of showing that
they're very very proud of being
Canadians that they're very contributing
citizens like everybody else
I must assure you that religion leaves
in our hearts this is only a sample we
are here to participate and celebrate
together what Canada is about then an
ally nog
it stands for peace it stands for love
spends for diversity stands for caring
one of the most Canadian citizenship
ceremonies Lee's seen because it
happened and an Islamic Center with a
bagpiper and a kilt with people from all
different types of backgrounds and
cultures so that's pretty much
multiculturalism Canada right there
you